[XYLOPHONE PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Imagine a
customer comes to you today
who wants to move to the cloud.
Perhaps they want to get better
insights from their business
data, or they want to
solve a complex problem
with machine learning.
Knowing how to
begin that journey
or how to structure it
well can be challenging.
With that in mind, I
want to introduce you
to the Google Cloud Professional
Services Organization, or PSO.
PSO's mission is to help
customers and partners get
the most out of
Google Cloud products.
So how do we do this?
By dedicating our expertise
to meeting customer business
challenges and working
with partners to support
complex customer projects.
This allows us to build
and recommend solutions
based on our proven
methodologies
and best practices gained
from field experience.
We also aim to educate customers
and partners on Google products
and to validate skills
through certifications.
A key goal throughout is to
enable our partners to deliver
exceptional value to customers.
So in this partnership, what
role do Google and the partner
play?
Google provides
strategic and technical
best practices
through PSO service
offerings to our partners.
Partners offer a combination
of field experience,
strong technical ability, and
in-depth customer knowledge.
They leverage the PSO
social services and assets
to structure and guide
customer projects.
The pillars of
PSO's business are
grouped into four categories.
The consulting services focus
on successfully delivering
specific projects and services.
We have consulting service
packages for both GCP and G
Suite.
Technical account management
ensures the long-term success
of our customer's
journey to the cloud.
Training and
certification services
ensure that your
staff or the customers
are brought up to speed
quickly on the latest knowledge
of Google Cloud products.
And partner services focus
on enabling and supporting
our partners.
These left three
pillars are our service
offerings aimed at customers.
Partners may want to build
a similar set of offerings
in their portfolio.
The partners services team
is here to help them do that.
The service offerings represent
the short-term project,
long-term advocacy, and
learning perspectives
of customer projects.
To support the successful
delivery of services, the PSO
team itself is divided
into practice areas,
each focused on a product
area or solution expertise.
Practice areas develop services
and assets unique to their area
and customer needs.
So why is this important to you?
Well, it not only
helps you understand
how our teams are
structured, but also how
our services and
partner specializations
are categorized.
For example, if
you have a customer
with a machine learning
project on GCP,
the type of best practices,
watch points, and business
needs will be very
different from what
would be needed for a
customer focused on a G Suite
deployment.
So let's talk about the
different methodologies
you can use.
As they are different
technologies
with different goals, we
have separate methodologies
for both GCP and G Suite.
Let's take a look at how these
methodologies can help you
structure your cloud projects.
The Google Cloud
Platform methodology
is based on a four-phase model
of the customer's journey
to the cloud.
Assess, plan, deploy, optimize.
During the assess
phase, the customer
is still questioning
their readiness
to move to the cloud or GCP.
They require guidance to
build confidence using GCP
and to assess feasibility
of a solution.
During the plan
phase, the customer
is convinced GCP
is right for them,
but they require your expertise
to plan for this journey
and to help design
their solution.
Deploy is when you'd implement
the proposed solution following
Google's best practices.
And in the optimized phase,
when the customer already
has solutions
running on GCP, you
bring expertise to improve
and enhance existing workloads
and to ensure that the
customer is still getting
the most out of the platform.
For each phase, multiple
service packages
are available to help
ensure you're meeting
your customer where they are.
The G Suite methodology
is a four-phase model
for customer success.
Excite, enable, expand, embed.
During the excite phase, you
engage with executive sponsors
to understand the customer's
key business objectives.
By delivering workshops, you
inform decisions and scope out
and plan the project.
The enable phase involves
the technical deployment
where you migrate the customer
from their legacy platform
to G Suite.
Here you also execute on the
training, communications,
and support plans.
The expand phase is all
about growing user adoption
of the G Suite services.
This is done by providing
training, optimizing support,
and transforming
business processes.
Finally, the embed phase
aims to solidify G Suite
into the customer's
business operations.
By measuring impact and
promoting success stories,
you can help the customer
to continuously innovate.
This phase helps to promote
new service opportunities.
At each of these phases, we have
different services and assets
designed to ensure success on
the platform with high adoption
and return on investment.
So where can you find
the tools, methodologies,
and best practices needed?
In Cloud Connect, the
official community for Google
Cloud partners.
In the Professional
Services section,
assets are shared with partners
and organized by practice area.
For example, for
infrastructure assets,
you go to that practice area.
And each PSO service offering,
such as Cloud Start or Cloud
Plan, is comprised
of assets that
will help you sell and deliver
the service to ensure customer
success.
If I click into Cloud Plan
Infrastructure for example,
you can see here that there are
plenty of assets and documents
to get you started
delivering these services.
You can see Cloud Connect
as your main source
for PSO content.
But what if you need more
training before you get
started delivering services?
The Google Cloud training
site has everything for you
to make the most of
Google Cloud technologies.
We offer learning tracks with
fundamental to advanced level
training courses.
Let's take the Cloud
Infrastructure learning track
as an example.
Here we see the Cloud
Platform Architect
track, which has various courses
for the different levels.
Can't be there in person?
You can complete some
courses online and on demand.
Google has teamed
up with Coursera
to offer Google
Cloud courses online
so you can scale
up from anywhere.
You can also click
Find a Class to locate
a specific instructor-like class
from one of our Google Cloud
authorized training partners
with live and virtual options.
There are also self-paced
labs in the form of Qwiklabs.
These hands-on labs
provide a cloud environment
to help you learn new skills.
You can practice
and build experience
using live cloud resources in
an authentic GCP environment.
Once you've gained
enough experience,
Google Certification
Program gives you
a way to demonstrate your
technical skills and expertise.
Lack of cloud
skills and knowledge
is the biggest barrier
to cloud adoption.
Grow your skills today.
So by now, you have an
overview of the Google Cloud
Professional Services
Organization, its mission,
structure, and methodologies.
And you've taken a look where
you can find more resources
and training to
partner with Google
and build your business further.
Thanks for watching.
[GUITAR PLAYING]